why don't we flip it on its head why
don't we start talking about
the uh gender
sex gap between men and women so
i know that i think it's the
bottom 80 of men
on tinder are competing for the bottom
20
of women oh yeah yeah that's right that
was uh that was a fascinating
uh finding yeah where they basically
found yeah exactly
what you're describing here that you
know
men who are not you know exceptionally
good looking or or have certain status
markers
they're having a much harder time on
tinder um
just to put this into perspective if i
recall these numbers
correctly men uh on average
swipe sixty percent of the female
profiles they see they like them was it
swipe swipe right you know they like
those profiles don't pretend you don't
know robert i know let me let me pull up
my app real quick
[Laughter]
um and then uh whereas women on the
other hand i think it was four percent
they swipe right on four percent
of the male profiles they see that is an
unbelievably
low number i mean just purely from a a
time investment standpoint you're gonna
get through a hundred people to get four
four right swipes and if you have a
particularly bad afternoon it's not a
not a ridiculous stat to think you might
not strike swipe right on anyone
unbelievable
it's almost like the experiences are
completely different right whereas
i mean like i once this this wasn't a
psychologist i just uh in a casual
conversation i once heard someone
describe
this the sort of difference between men
and women in terms of
you know how they evaluate the opposite
sex or is something like
men look for reasons why they wouldn't
sleep with a girl
whereas women look for reasons why they
would sleep with a man so the default
position for man is
you know i would sleep with her unless
there's some extraordinary
reason why i shouldn't whereas for women
it's i'm definitely not going to sleep
with him unless there's some particular
reason why i should
um and this is sort of you know we're
seeing this on tinder right with with
the frequency of of
of right swipes so uh yeah so basically
there's a large group of men who are
collecting
large numbers of likes i have a friend
and you probably know guys like this who
are racking up huge
huge numbers on these dating apps um
yeah i have a friend who has you know
something like 20
000 plus uh matches on tinder i think he
closed it down he ended up getting a
relationship and
he settled down but for for a while he
didn't i'm surprised he didn't break the
[ __ ]
servers yeah closed it down because
tinder came in
and they said oh sorry we just can't
give this account any more storage space
with your 20
000 likes yeah shut it all down um
no it's actually the opposite um i don't
know how this happened but he was uh
tinder identified him as like some kind
of valuable
user and like gave him all of these
perks and benefits and like lifted his
limitations on
how many fights was it like amazon prime
or something you
if you've ever if you've ever actually
spent more than a thousand pounds in a
year on booking.com you get to become a
genius
and booking.com being a booking.com
genius is fantastic you get 10 off you
get early check-in
so i wonder if he got like early
check-in yeah essentially the equivalent
of that no i haven't i've never
gotten those privileges sometimes amazon
sends me complimentary protein bars
nice uh because i order so many of them
but i've never uh never never anything
like free amazon prime
but um but yeah so you have guys like
like my friend here who has all of these
likes
and then you have other guys and i think
this is probably more typical of the
mail experience on dating apps
where you know they go through you know
dozens or hundreds of profiles and and
get maybe a handful
of of uh matches with women um
and so yeah this is this is sort of the
typical male experience where
you know the the the competition isn't
as tough
and one thing i'm concerned about now
with with the economic downturn is that
it could get tougher
um as women more guys losing their jobs
yeah yeah a handful of guys maybe you
know guys guys who can work from home
you know podcasters and so on who
you know have stay at home gigs you know
things might might turn out pretty good
for
for them but for other guys hoping rob
he is hoping mate
i'm [ __ ] praying i just been praying
for a pandemic to happen so that my
dating dayton situation can improve
[Music]